welcome please take your seats the event
is about to begin
please take your seats the event is
about to begin thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
laughs
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
good morning and welcome
with deep appreciation and gratitude to
the Quinnipiac people the indigenous
people on Whose Land We assemble my dear
Yale Community please join me in a
moment of prayer or reflection
loving and holy spirit called on by many
names Creator and sustainer of life
We Gather here today with anticipation
and nervousness
as we embark on this next academic year
Hold Us gently and with care
May our time on this beautiful campus be
full of light and Truth transformation
and growth may we be open to awe and
surprise in Wonder of wisdom and
creation
as the world overflows with Brokenness
may this be a year of mending of
restoration and renewal
remind us to be humble before the vast
knowledge of the universe wisdom that is
known not yet known and unknowable
Spirit of Wonder and Delight
help us to embrace vulnerability to know
human beings are not perfect and there
is perfect and room for growth in the
imperfections
help us continue to move forward despite
the fears that linger in our minds
remind us that failure leads to
Innovation and creativity
remind us to play and find joy and
Whimsy in the moments that punctuate our
days
help us find our purpose
sacred breath of the universe we come
here today as the fruition of our
ancestors wildest dreams
may we live into being good ancestors
ourselves
we have inherited knowledge and
traditions may we shape them for a
better future for all
may we embark on this journey and grow
from strength to strength as we say Amen
please be seated
class of 2027.
transfer students Eli Whitney students
and visiting International students
welcome to Yale
a Provost Strobel chaplain Saltillo
other university leaders good morning
and parents Guardians families and
friends gathered here welcome and good
morning to you and thank you for
everything that you have done in guiding
and supporting these young adults
thanks to the families
I'm delighted that you and your students
are joining the Yale community
this opening assembly is one of my
favorite
formal events of the academic year
because it's one of the times that we
all come together in Fellowship
it's also your first day as new members
of this community students you come here
today as strangers but in the days and
years ahead you will become colleagues
and Friends many of you for life
learning from and teaching one another
together with the faculty and staff you
have joined a community that shares a
love of learning Yale is a special kind
of community and in this regard I like
to recall the words of civil rights
activist and Yale alumna Paulie Murray
who said
[Applause]
sorry I don't have a lot of quotes from
all the other uh colleges heads but
anyway Paulie Murray is always a good
one uh true Community is based upon
equality mutuality and reciprocity
it affirms the richness of individual
diversity as well as the common human
ties that bind us together
as a college we are also bound together
by the search for knowledge and by the
task of helping young people to reach
their full potential
you join a great tradition shaped by the
many generations of students who've come
before you from every imaginable
background and Walk of Life this week
more than sixteen hundred of you have
come to New Haven from all over the
world no single racial or ethnic group
forms a majority among the student body
more than a fifth of you will be among
the first generation in your family to
complete a four-year college degree and
more than a fifth of you have received
Pell Grants for lower income students
130 of you applied through the quest
bridge program 38 were admitted through
the transfer and Eli Whitney students
programs and 10 of you are U.S military
veterans
22 of you began your college education
at a community college together you
represent 53 U.S states and territories
and more than 60 countries you come to
Yale from a range of religious
backgrounds cultural traditions and
political beliefs and amidst this great
diversity you also share much in common
your promising students with wide
Horizons and an excitement about
learning and together you've come to
Yale to pursue a broad liberal education
as you look around here today you can
see the physical embodiment of our
community of learning here we stand in
front of Sterling Memorial Library the
heart of Campus which holds over three
million books on all fields of knowledge
around us are some of Yale's residential
colleges where you will live eat and
learn together
the first residential colleges in the
west were constructed at Oxford in the
13th century for students at the
University there and a lot of our campus
architecture Echoes Oxford's Gothic
style
colleges today maintain some of the air
of the medieval Cloister they offer
young people an opportunity to develop
to develop away from the pressures of
the broader Society so that they can
later make contributions beyond the
college Gates
the father of English poetry Jeffrey
Chaucer paints a famous picture of a
student at Oxford who wears a threadbare
cloak rides an emaciated horse and is
rather underfed himself so dedicated is
the student to learning that when he
gets some money from his friends he
spends it not on fine clothes or a new
horse or even food for himself but on
books about philosophy and Chaucer
concludes this Unforgettable portrait of
the Oxford student by saying gladly what
he learn and gladly teach
has Chaucer knew more than 700 years ago
the essential character of college life
is not just the attention that the
colleges pay to the needs of the body
but I will assure the parents that we
intend to keep the kids well fed
um
instead it's the sense of a group of
friends and classmates who learn
together and who teach one another and
this is what social scientists call the
pure effect it's something that we
academics are at risk of neglecting
namely that students can in the right
environment learn as much from their
interactions with each other in student
societies and team sports at improv
nights or orchestra rehearsals or in
study groups in late night conversations
as they do in their formal coursework
so why do we educate students in a
communal setting let's go back even
further to Plato's academy one of the
first institutions of Higher Learning in
his book The Republic Plato envisions a
communal education for the leaders of
his ideal city
the leaders will be chosen by
meritocratic state examinations they
will live and eat together will have no
private property of their own and will
study philosophy the Greek word for the
love of wisdom
Plato also proposes very unusually for
his time that women and men should have
exactly the same education
Plato believed that such an education
would develop leaders who are dedicated
to the city and Justice above all else
who do not consider their own private
gain in making decisions and to have the
moral character to avoid corruption
now a few of us today would subscribe to
Plato's anti-democratic views or his
insistence on the abolition of private
property and the nuclear family but the
education you receive at Yale does have
something in common with Plato's ideals
we don't require that you major in
philosophy I think the dean of the
faculty of Arts and Sciences would not
mind if you chose to but we do hope that
you will study the love of wisdom for
its own sake and we hope that you'll
follow the long-standing Yale tradition
of developing your character and
pursuing a life of service
this education will prepare you for
leadership in all walks of society
Yale's not just one Community but many
and depending on your interests you
might join several of them including
student clubs Arts organizations sports
teams cultural centers and identity
groups Faith groups and political
parties
the sense of belonging in multiple
overlapping communities is one of the
most positive effects of college life
it's what I think of as collisional
frequency in physics and chemistry
Collision frequency refers to the rate
at which two atoms or molecules bump
into each other in a particular volume
metaphorically I think if collisional
frequency as the frequency with which we
bump into each other on campus sparking
new ideas and conversations and Yale is
brilliantly designed to increase the
frequency of encounters like these
the word Community derives from the
notion of the common or shared it often
has a religious overtone of people who
share a spiritual bond and University
leaders and and religious political and
corporate leaders as well tend to speak
of community in unreservedly positive
tones but anyone who's actually belonged
to a community knows that it's
impossible to avoid tensions when living
together with other people
and communities can sometimes ask too
much of us across cultures how
individuals should relate to their
communities remains alive debate
here I come back to the notion of a
community of learning our shared purpose
here at Yale is to learn from one
another and to teach one another and
that means respecting and encouraging
each other's freedom and autonomy it's
what Paulie Murray meant when she spoke
of equality mutuality and reciprocity
college is a particular kind of
community one where people come from a
range of backgrounds and are united not
around a single religious tradition or a
single cultural background or even a
single National nationality but around
the desire to learn
it welcomes the full range of
perspectives it depends on mutual
respect and it invites every kind of
debate judging each argument by the
standards of reason and evidence it also
Embraces the learning of many times and
places it develops citizens of the world
asked about the study of English
literature the literature of India's
colonial government Mahatma Gandhi
encouraged his people to study both
English and their native languages and
he offers an image of the Collision of
cultures that I love
he said I do not want my house to be
walled in on all sides and my windows to
be stuffed I want the cultures of all
the lands to be blown about my house as
freely as possible
but I refuse to be blown off my feet by
any
Yale is the kind of Cosmopolitan
community of learning where you will
encounter cultures of all the lands and
where you can learn together
I trust that like Chaucer's clerk you
will be glad to learn and teach
I hope that like Plato's students you
will pursue lives of service
I expect that like Gandhi will open
yourselves to the cultures of the world
and I pray with Paulie Murray that you
will treat each other with equality
mutuality and reciprocity
you will find Yale a welcoming place to
learn and you will remain a part of this
community for the rest of your lives
thank you and welcome to Yale
foreign
[Music]
we have
A Light Special
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all around us
[Music]
now is
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning
I'm sorry that I cannot be there with
you in person today
although I feel fine I tested positive
for covid yesterday and in accordance
with the University's Health guidelines
I'm staying home
however I'm delighted to join you
through video
gives me great pleasure to welcome you
our entering students and your family
members to campus
and to Mark officially the start of your
undergraduate education
this is a big moment for you and for
yell
I'm glad this day has arrived and I'm so
glad you are here
it is evident why you belong at Yale
your academic distinction leadership
Savvy and outstanding motivation
solidify your standing among students
who have sat for centuries where you are
sitting today
what is more the richness of your
diversity across every Dimension
reflects Yale's commitment to creating
an inclusive educational environment
now as you prepare to enter Yale
and leave your unique imprint on it
allow me to alert you
to a perennial observation among our
alumni
many of your predecessors I must caution
have marveled that the Breakneck clip at
which today's festivities
give way to your graduation
it's a hard truth codified in one of
Yale's most celebrated traditions
singing of our unofficial alma mater
bright college Years
your time here is described as the
shortest Gladys years of life
and as gliding by
swiftly in fact
so I encourage you to savor the
qualities that Drew you to this
remarkable place
between the ceremonies that will bookend
your bright college Years I encourage
you to remain ever aware that time here
moves at warp speed
as you set off on the Grand Adventure of
a liberal education though
I want also to impart a bit of wisdom
today I want to urge you to cultivate
the habit of moving deliberately
systematically
slowly
not necessarily to blunt the wistfulness
you may feel in four years time
but to reflect on the ideas to which you
will be exposed and to be in a position
to repair what is broken in the world
you will then enter
as perhaps never before this year's
cohort of new undergraduate students has
come of age in a culture of haste
yours is a generation that has never
known life without the instant spread of
information
social networking was born before nearly
all of you
similarly novel technologies that were
Unthinkable in my generation
are native to yours
many of the Innovations on which society
has come to rely are the fruit of a
mantra first articulated by Mark
Zuckerberg move fast and break things he
instructed his staff at Facebook around
the time of its 2004 launch
unless you are breaking stuff he
continued you are not moving fast enough
to be sure this Mantra was eventually
phased out as Facebook's motto
but it remains very much a prevailing
ethos that animates today's Tech
ecosystem
Blitz scaling as LinkedIn co-founder
Reed Hoffman characterized it drives
lightning growth by prioritizing speed
over efficiency even in an environment
of uncertainty
of course this ethos has seeped into the
DNA of newer online platforms that
prioritize rather detrimentally speed
over depth platforms that can Stoke our
emotional impulses all while suppressing
our capacity to think broadly and engage
with ideas that challenge us
the emerging Frontier of artificial
intelligence has given us a glimpse into
its potential
to compound these tendencies
so rather than move fast and break
things
I say here today slow down and fix
now I am not a Luddite I treasure the
benefits of technological advance to our
lives and our relationships here on
campus for example the kova 19 pandemic
highlighted the extraordinary usefulness
of digital tools and sustaining our
educational mission
and allowing us to cope and connect with
one another
amid social isolation and hardship and
sometimes Tech is just plain fun I can
spend hours on YouTube checking out
Appalachian music from past decades
but the propensity we have developed for
the immediate
deprives us of a time and space
necessary for careful reflection
social media feeds can bait us with the
hollow lures of likes and then bombard
us with viewpoints that reinforce indeed
intensify our most strongly held
assumptions
we consume what we already believe to be
true
and have largely shielded therefore from
what is
so I encourage you
slow down
and fix things
to place this advice in context I'd like
to draw upon my field of study the
discipline of psychology
last year I had the special privilege of
engaging in a public dialogue about
generative AI with Professor Daniel
Kahneman a Nobel prize-winning
psychologist known best for his field
changing research on decision-making
heuristics and biases
years ago my lab relied on his work to
conduct research on how to make Health
messages more persuasive
and Yale was proud to bestow on him an
honorary degree in 2014.
in his book Thinking Fast and Slow
Professor Kahneman details how our minds
are governed by two systems system one
is the fast one it's based on emotion
reflex and stereotype
and it makes us gullible therefore and
biased to believe
system two is the slow one in charge of
doubting and unbelieving through
analytical deliberate and rational
thought
the confirmatory bias of system one he
says in short favors uncritical
acceptance of suggestions and
exaggerations of the likelihood of
extreme and improbable events
well we can see here the hazards of
nurturing it as a default way of
thinking particularly in a time of
upheaval and unrest
of course as members of the class of
2027 your most formative years coincided
with moments of monumental consequence
in high school you witnessed a once in a
generation pandemic and the virulent
spread of conspiracy theories about it
you saw violent insurrectionists disrupt
the most basic functioning of our
democracy
and Vladimir Putin launched the largest
ground war in Europe since the Second
World War
you have seen and some of you have
participated in transformative social
and cultural movements
and as recently as this summer you
experience the hottest recorded week in
history even as some deny the severity
in fact the existence
of the climate emergency
so I sense you might rightfully feel
among a mix of other emotions a burning
desire to pursue Speedy action
but our commitment to looks at where it
has to light in truth compels us to slow
down to listen to each other to deal
with complex and sometimes conflicting
ideas
to engage in deep thoughtfulness
and then to look for ways to fix things
now let me be clear
this is not to suggest that the pace of
progress
ought to be glacial
know the challenges confronting Society
demand our restlessness to improve the
world for this and future Generations
patience is University president Kingman
Brewster Jr told incoming members of a
Yale College class is not come by easily
in a world for which survival is a
serious question
and that was to the class of 1974.
so where then he asked is the purpose
which makes patient learning supportable
as president Brewster would go on to
insinuate enduring institutional
progress takes not only knowledge but
understanding
Solutions born of even the most
well-founded scientific or historical
expertise
still require the public will to
implement them
changing other people's minds requires
us to expand our own
breakthroughs are brought about in a
chorus
not an echo chamber
we must take time to think
deliberatively if we want to fix things
let me provide an example from two Yale
College alumni David Brockman and Joshua
Calla political scientists the latter of
whom is at Yale
professors Brockman and Cala focus on
political persuasion public opinion and
Prejudice reduction
and there's signal work on transgender
rights and immigration
in forms and guides meaningful action
and these and other Realms of public
discourse
they found that the inclination to
correct others who did not see the World
As We Do
May provide emotional relief
but it is not likely to persuade in
their words in fact expressing such
frustration can make people Harden their
existing views
deep canvassing that is non-judgmentally
exchanging narratives in interpersonal
conversations
can facilitate durable reductions in
exclusionary attitudes
okay so they dispatch dozens of
door-to-door canvasses in the wake of a
new law to protect transgender people
from discrimination
one group of canvassers said nothing to
Residents about transphobia
while the other asks sensitive questions
listen to the answers with sincere
interests and then ask more questions
the result
well here's what they said not everyone
was swayed but on average the group
engaged in the deeper thoughtful
interactions experienced a drop in
transphobia even greater than the fall
in homophobia among Americans from 1998
to 2012.
the canvassers by listening sincerely
patiently
had produced the equivalent of 14 years
of social change
so we must undertake the rigorous
painstaking and yes sometimes plotting
task of listening carefully to the broad
range of perspectives that surround us
instead of Blazing forth complacently
we must Elevate the virtues indeed the
value of patience and a willingness to
listen to ideas we don't like
and reject a counterproductive culture
of calling out denunciation and
ostracism
in an obvious paradox
slowing down can achieve faster more
effective results
and thinking of this imperative I'm
reminded of Reverend Tish Harrison
Warren's recent exploration of patience
as a virtue with the Yale Divinity
schools Center for Faith and culture
internet advocacy our very connected
world does make us a less patient people
I mean that in both ways she says less
patient for change
but also less patient with one another
it takes real work to slow down and
listen to another person's perspective
especially if you disagree
I think two of the late Rabbi Lord
Jonathan sacks another honorary Yale
degree recipient I referenced today who
expressed powerfully that arguments are
won only by giving your opponent a
hearing
hear it Yale and at colleges and
universities like it we advance this
worthy Endeavor by educating students to
seek out competing ideas to evaluate
evidence to mobilize the tools of reason
and critical inquiry
yes this takes time patience
but the effortful system 2 motive
thinking a liberal education promotes
cultivates collaboration
and thereby propels sweeping
contributions to our world
that is I think what makes education the
strongest force available
it is what makes patient learning
supportable
in fact essential
I take as my final words today a part of
what Rabbi Sachs wrote on the merits of
engaging with diverse perspectives
Jewish scholarship and the first century
BCE he noted was Riven by a series of
controversies between the schools of two
great rabbis Hillel and shamai
eventually the views of Rabbi Hillel
prevailed on most issues
the talmud explains why
the Disciples of Hillel were pleasant
and did not take offense
and they taught the views of their
opponents as well as their own
indeed they taught the views of their
opponents Before Their Own
he might have said
sick looks at where it has light and
Truth
through ADI alteram partum
listening to the other side
that is if Rabbi Hillel spoke Latin
here in the arena of higher education I
am sure you will do so here you will
find an oasis if not an island of the
pensive interdependent thought process
through which positive change advances
and then in due course you will be well
positioned to put this Hallmark of your
Yale education
to work in the world
you will know that taking the time to
see the whole of a problem to create
something lasting and beneficial and to
build consensus
even and most especially with those
whose worldview does not align with your
own is not an impediment
but a prerequisite to progress
even as you slow down and contemplate
New Perspectives you will still hold
fast to your ideals and move
thoughtfully Faithfully to fulfill them
I am pleased to welcome you to Yale
today
I am pleased to advise you
slow down
fix things
[Applause]
[Music]
oh crushing him
just
breathing and close your eyes
[Music]
raise your voices
we use
[Music]
praise your
wishes
[Music]
[Applause]
Lord
[Music]
[Applause]
from all corners of the world we've
gathered today a resplendent tapestry of
experience and wisdom
ready to embrace a New Year together
to build community and engage in
self-discovery
as we mark this life transition may we
do so with Grace and tenderness knowing
goodbyes help leave room for hellos and
New Beginnings
May our feelings of homesickness be
replaced by feelings of grounding and
home
may this campus be a place of
transformation and pride
may we be a blessing may we move with a
heart towards Justice with a mind of
curiosity
with arms open with compassion
with a soul of Grace
let us go forth today with the Deep
knowledge that each of us is precious
and needed right here in this moment
may we go inhaling love and exhaling
peace as we say Amen
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello class of 2027 my name is Jeff
Dalma I'm the director of the Yale glee
club and we have the great pleasure to
introduce you to Bright college Years
our unofficial alma mater and a song
will you will hear and sing during your
time at Yale
in four years at class day on the day
before you graduate
surrounded by your classmates just as
you are now we will sing it together
again led by one of you the future Glee
Club president
I invite you all to join in the words
and music are on the card on your seat
and as generations of yales have done
before you wave your handkerchiefs High
while singing the song's last line for
God for country and for Yale
we are conducted by the current Glee
Club president a war on Guru
[Applause]
[Music]
there is
[Applause]
[Music]
oh let us
[Applause]
[Music]
for God for
country and for years
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign foreign